[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in mike florio pro football
talk live co-host mike let's let's start
there sorry hit you so early in the
morning with something so serious well
no i just had a bowl of milk with some
cereal in it so uh it's a perfect
perfect segue who in the world would put
the milk in first the the the milk
splashes everywhere when you pour the
cereal in
and the milk possibly overflows
the bowl as you pour the cereal in no
you put the cereal then the milk i've
never heard of anyone doing milk then
cereal until today all right well thank
you mike that's all we need okay good
yeah good um all right so uh we thought
about florio as soon as the news
happened with deshawn watson we thought
all right let's see if uh mike even
though he's on vacation can help us it's
not vacation it's not vacation but
that's all right we're on hiatus i'm
still working it's not a vacation no
days off just like bill belichick okay
um why now
why did desean watson settle now
well it's a great question because last
week he was asked are you going to
settle the cases and he says no i want
to clear my name i i want to see this
court process through and my reaction
was it's too late to clear your name
this has been hanging around for 15
months there are 24 plaintiffs two more
supposedly are suing attorney tony busby
suggested last week there could be even
more who will sue the new york times
identified not by name but the number of
at least 66 women out there who
potentially could at some point get
involved in this so
i just think that
desean watson finally realized
it was time
and there's no way out of this you're
never going to clear your name it's it's
just too late it should have happened
before the first case was filed it
should have happened in april of last
year they were ready to get these
settled and it fell apart he could have
settled 18 of 22 lawsuits last october
wanted to do all or nothing i think he
finally realized i need to knock out as
many of these as i can i need to resolve
as many of these as i can because if
you're going to go to trial against 24
different people that is going to take
if football season season's out of play
dan that's going to take two or three
years to try all those cases now he's
down to four they ultimately may be down
to zero but by taking 20 of these cases
off the table
it it accelerates
the moment at which this is all going to
be over for desean watts and i think
he's just gotten to the point where he
realizes i need this to be over
is this an admission of guilt
it's never an admission of guilt when
you settle a civil claim and in many
cases what happens is there's a very
objective analysis of the situation how
much more is it going to cost me in
legal fees to take this case all the way
through to a verdict even if i win how
much will it cost me to resolve this
case right now if it's less or equal and
you're buying certainty by settling the
case it's a smart business decision
however and even though the paperwork
will say
there is no admission of guilt i've
written hundreds of these documents over
the years it will be very clear there's
no in in any way shape or form
acknowledgement of responsibility people
are going to say well if you pay
anything you must have done it if you
were innocent you would fight it and
that's just an inaccurate conclusion now
in some cases it's accurate but i think
as a broad brush blanket statement it's
not accurate the other thing too dan if
there was just one plaintiff and you put
in a confidentiality provision
chances are no one's ever going to talk
with 20 of these folks out there
able to hide behind the other 19 any one
of them that blabs i didn't do it
there's 19 others somebody eventually is
gonna say what was paid here and a
hundred thousand was offered per
plaintiff back in october it'll be
interesting to see when we find out the
real number and i think we eventually
will
a hundred thousand plus how much to
settle now i wonder about settling and
if what role the nfl had in maybe
advising
if you settle or you know there there's
a
there's going to be a punishment here i
don't i don't know if it all works
together mike and maybe i'm trying to
i'm trying to put together a jigsaw
puzzle and they're two different puzzles
no but i think you're right i think your
instincts are right and we always know
that there's a sausage making process
behind the scenes and i think that it
was getting to the point dan starting
with the hbo story on the case and then
another lawsuit is filed and then desean
watson's lawyer makes the awkward
comment about there's nothing criminal
about a happy ending and then another
lawsuit's filed and then the new york
times story comes out it just felt like
it was disintegrating
and there had been voices in the league
office for a long time that believe
deshawn watson shouldn't play until all
these cases are over now the
commissioner took paid leave off the
table in march that doesn't mean it
couldn't be put back on and lately it
was feeling to me like you know the best
outcome is press pause on this guy's
career let him focus on these 24 cases
and counting
and then we'll impose an unpaid
suspension after that i think it's a
practical matter and maybe there was a
conversation off the grid and you know
how this happens three layers deep and
this conversation never occurred but it
could be somebody from the league office
got the message to watson's camp look
what you need to do is settle these
cases because there's just too many of
them we can't let this guy play with
this many pending legal cases you're
going to settle them eventually
settle them now
and and i think that makes it far less
likely he will be put on paid leave
because i was thinking as of last week
paid leave
felt like it was inevitable because
there was just too much hovering over to
sean watts it was last friday when the
washington post mark maskey said that uh
quoting that uh expecting a significant
punishment for deshaun watson
i asked a source i said somebody
involved in this i said what is
significant mean to you and he said well
my significant is different than what
the commissioner's significant is or
desean watson's camp or the cleveland
browns what do you think is the
punishment for deshaun watson i was told
a day before maskie's report that the
nflpa is bracing for something
unprecedented
so
and and you got to remember the
procedure that's going to be at play
here first the league proposes a
punishment so they start high then
independent retired judge gets involved
and makes decision maybe it's something
lower
then commissioner has
jurisdiction over the appeal and the
league can appeal the league can say we
asked for a year
judge robinson who's going to be in
charge of this said eight games we think
it should be a year commissioner could
say i'll do 12. so there's a back and
forth that can happen here so yeah you
start high because you assume that
through this process the independent
disciplinary officer is going to come in
lower and then the commissioner decides
what the final outcome is going to be so
it doesn't surprise me that it would be
a year it wouldn't surprise me if it's
longer than a year frankly the trevor
bauer suspension by mlb i think as a
practical matter resonates in what the
nfl does with deshaun watson so i i
think it will be unprecedented i think
it will be significant and at the end of
the day roger goodell is going to have
final say he's mike florio pro football
talk live co-host with chris sims the
show that precedes hours on peacock
monday through friday help me understand
daniel snyder's situation yet another
situation so he's got one situation
going on and then news came out about
another situation where he settled a
sexual uh
whatever harassment suit
um
why why is it that he doesn't get
punished for any of this but deshawn
watson is going to get punished for this
dan that's a great point it's a it's a
perfect segue to the snyder situation
because we reported last week and
masking confirmed this the nflpa when
defending deshawn watson one of the
defenses will be
any discipline of desean watson must be
proportional to
discipline imposed on owners who have
run afoul of the personal conduct policy
because the common policy says in black
and white
owners and team management are held to a
higher standard so if daniel snyder
is punished and i still don't even know
what his punishment is is he running the
team is he not running the team who the
hell knows but it sounds like it's
punishment to make him run the team yeah
that's true especially for the fans but
um
you know whatever they did to schneider
and the other two owners that the nflpa
is going to pull into this robert craft
who had a similar similar a lot of
differences but some similarities to
deshaun watson no punishment all that
anyone knows of jerry jones the cowboys
owner had that voyeurism scandal that
bubbled up earlier this year involving
rich dalrymple the former pr guru of the
cowboys never investigated by the league
never punished by the league as far as
anyone knows who knows how
how
broadly that scandal went we don't know
so the union is gonna push very
aggressively the idea whatever you do to
these guys
it's got to be more than what you do to
sean watson so we have to view the final
punishment through that prism and what
it does is a practical matter it draws
these guys into this fight and they're
not gonna want that so it puts pressure
on the league that may not have
otherwise been there but as to snyder
look today's the hearing before the
house oversight committee and the
commissioner issued a lengthy statement
this morning he's gonna testify he's
gonna get some tough questions and he
can't do his press conference tap dance
where somebody asks a question he
doesn't answer it and then somebody else
asks a question about something
completely different and he never gets
pressed to truly and fully answer a
question
what are the legal consequences of this
hearing
well
ostensibly what congress is looking to
do is explore possible litigation not
litigation excuse me legislation that
could be
aimed at improving the workplace
experience for people coast to coast and
already two bills have been introduced
by the chairperson of the committee as
it relates to the use of non-disclosure
agreements in the workplace setting and
the use of images of the employee that
are harvested in the course of
employment because one of the one of the
issues here one of the many issues what
was done with some outtakes of a
cheerleader video that ended up
allegedly with upper management of the
team for their entertainment apparently
but um the
the bottom line is congress does have
this authority when you consider i had
this conversation with someone yesterday
because the knee-jerk reaction by so
many of congress enough congress have
better things to do well they have other
things to do but they're capable of
doing many things and when the nfl
number one is the beneficiary of a
50-year almost 60-year broadcast
anti-trust exemption that allows it to
go out and sell its tv rights in bulk
and when the nfl is the one thing that
is left in this country that can pull 20
30 40 million people together and watch
the same thing at the same time nothing
else does that anymore there's some
scrutiny that goes along with that so
that's where this all comes from and
they're trying to get to the bottom of
it and i applaud them dan because
they've been hiding the truth for months
now about what really happened they've
buried it
and congress is trying to get some of it
to come to light and i think it's a good
thing before i let you go gronk
announces his retirement
didn't sound like an actual retirement
announcement
but it was almost like i don't know what
i'm going to do but uh if you're asking
me today i'm going to retire but if tom
calls then i'll prob when your agent
says yes like
drew rose i've never seen this before
the agent says i don't believe my client
it was like when charles barkley said he
was misquoted in his in his
autobiography it's like your
autobiography how do you misquote it so
dan i think this is the bottom line the
bottom line is the bottom line i don't
think that that gronk is willing to come
out and say it but if if they're gonna
pay him eight nine ten million when
you've got receivers scratching against
30 million per year now and you look at
the weapon that gronk is i think for
anything less than 15 million i'm not
getting out of bed if i'm rob gronkowski
so if you're willing to pay me eight
nine or 10 million then i'll show up in
november and take that or some prorated
amount you want me there from day one i
want to be paid commensurately with the
top tight ends 15 is the high water mark
for tight ends you got receivers like i
said getting close to 30. i think it it
comes down to how much money the
buccaneers are willing to pay and
gronk's not going to come out and say it
because it just looks unseemly it looks
greedy if you say it
great stuff mike once again you're just
on hiatus you're not on vacation
hiatus no days off profitballtalk.com
every single day we stay and we can't we
have no choice
it's the fruit keeps falling out of the
trees every day
congratulations on your book playmakers
uh best seller thanks pal thank you mike
that's mike flora